[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravie de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui j'ai le très grand plaisir
la très grande chance d'être en présence
de Christian Roudeau il est journaliste
spécialisé en politique étrangère il est
aussi euh réalisateur de documentaires
et auteur de nombreux livre alors
justement aujourd'hui euh bah Christian
Roudeau déjà bonjour bonjour merci
d'être là euh vous êtes yvelinois entre
autres mais ce qui nous intéresse aussi
c'est que vous allez parler vous parler
d'un yvlinois votre dernier livre vient
de sortir chez euh chez Talandier dans
la collection texto voilà et vous
évoquez euh ça s'appelle à la table des
tyrans et vous évoquez six tyrans et
leurs habitudes culinaires si je puis
dire donc on va les nommer Mao Hitler
Staline bookasa chaouescu et Sadam husin
alors celui qui m'a tapé dans l'œil
c'est bokasa parce qu'il a vécu un
moment dans les ivelines au château
d'ardricour et on y reviendra plus
précisément tout à l'heure voilà alors
vous donc vous êtes journaliste vous
vous uvrez sur le au journal d'Arté et
aussi dans l'émission 28 minutes tout à
d'accord et vous avez produit donc des
documentaires de de différents livres
alors je me demandais ce ce thème de la
table qui est récurrent chez vous c'est
venu comment il y a eu un déclic
qu'est-ce qui fait que vous intéress
c'est un peu le fait du hasard
c'est-à-dire queon m'a demandé de
coécrire un livre avec un dénommé Gilles
Bragard qui a monté ce club des chefs
d'État ce club des chef cuisiners des
chefs d'État pour être précis sor de G20
de la cuisine de d'ord des palais et en
l'occurrence je m'intéresse beaucoup à
la politique et à la politique étrangère
un peu moins à la gastronomie donc ça a
été une sorte de mariage on a coécrit ce
livre où c'était passionnant où j'ai
rencontré tous les chefs de la reine
d'Angleterre du président Obama du
président Hollande à l'époque et ça
c'était vraiment passionnant et donc au
fil de mes rencontres et bien j'ai
commencé à glaner quelques anecdotes sur
bah des grands dictateur du 20e siècle
ceux qui par exemple étaient un peu les
plus récents g ça Saddam Hussein
chaousescou et bien évidemment c'est ça
qui m'a intéressé qui vous a passionné
et alors donc j'ai ça répond un peu à ma
question mais on on va un petit peu
creusé vous les avez sélectionnés
comment parce que malheureusement il y
en a peut-être plus que six sur cette
pauvre terre le 20e siècle a été un
grand pourvoyeur de dictateur et je
n'avais que l'embarras du choix alors si
j'ose dire j'ai choisi ben les les
meilleurs si si je pe me permettre donc
à savoir les pires les pires ses à
manger je pense que bon Adolf Hitler euh
Mao Staline Staline qui était
probablement le plus effrayant parce
qu'il faisait boire ses invités et in
votka Veritas si jamais la langue
pouvait fourcher on pouvait être en
difficulté donc voilà et puis je me suis
intéressé à des dictateurs d'un de
moindre envergure mais quand même des
dictateurs qui ont fait parler beaucoup
en leur temps à savoir shaousesku en
Roumanie bokasa en centrefrique et puis
Saddam Hussein en Irak tout à fait alors
voilà bon ben écoutez je comprends mieux
et alors
est-ce qu'ils ont des points communs ces
tyran est-ce qu'ils ont des habitudes
communes ou pas alors il est évident que
la mégalomanie fait partie du décorom
c'est-à-dire rien n'est trop beau rien
n'est trop bon pour ces dictateurs qui
veulent en mettre plein la vue si je
puis dire à leurs invités ça c'est un
très commun chez les dictateurs il y a
aussi bien évidemment la paranoïa la
peur de se faire empoisonner tous tous
craignent l'empoisonnement avec
certaines raison il faut savoir que même
dans les démocraties une cuisine d'un
palais une cuisine d'une présidence est
quand même surveillé d'assez près parce
que c'est une façon assez facile
d'atteindre le chef de l'État ou le
dictateur et en l'occurrence les
dictateurs ils ont quand même un certain
nombre d'ennemis donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui est vérifié mais effectivement
notamment Staline était de notoriété
public paranoïque et lors de ses repas
il faisait en sorte que les autres les
autres invités mangent avant lui pour
être certain que voilà il y avait rien
de dangereux dans dans dans la
nourriture donc ça c'est une évidence
mais la grande découverte dans mon libre
dans mon livre à la table des tyran ce
que j'ai vraiment mis en avant sur ces
six terribles dictateurs c'est le fait
que ils ont tous expérimenter la fin ils
ont tous connu la fin puisque cinq
d'entre eux viennent de milieu très
pauvres et donc il y a une sorte de
revanche sociale et qui ensuite lorsque
on a tous les attributs du pouvoir bah
la table c'est le moment où on peut se
traiter dignement y compris Adolf Hitler
qui lui vient de milieu plutôt
privilégié petite bourgeoisie mais qui
lorsqu'il a eu son expérience d'artiste
raté à
Vienne il roule pas sur l'or il a été à
la soup populaire et c'est d'ailleurs
son expérience de la fin il la met en
avant dans mcampf dans son livre panflé
en
montrant un badge de vertu en disant
peuple allemand comme toi j'ai souffert
de la fin donc c'est une façon parce que
c'est il invente quelque part je dirais
la
gastrocommunication même si peut-être on
n'est pas très loin de Versailles à
Louis XIV déjà aussi ça c'était le la
splendeur du Grand Siècle hein ces
grands repas mais il y a une
gastrocomunication moderne qu'on
retrouve chez Adolf Hitler la
gastropolitique la gastropolitique qui
existe encore toujours c'estàd qu'à la
fois je pense qu'on a un bon exemple
alors là on parle pas d'un dictateur on
parle de Jacques Chirac Jacques Chirac
de notoriété publique qui s'est
construit un personnage sur le côté bon
mangeur c'est une façon de log on tape
le voilà la tranche de saucisson la
fameuse tête de veau qui ne mangeait pas
tant que ça finalement non non non il en
a mangé deux fois à l'Élysée mais parce
que justement il av s'est cuisiné
arrêtez de me faire de la tête de veau
parce qu'il pouvait plus faire un pas
parce que c'était ça avait été dévoilé
le fait qu'il aimait la tête de veau et
et donc voilà il y en avait un petit peu
de trop plein mais tout ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que euh finalement ça
reste un instrument de politique le
prisme de la table d'une table du
pouvoir raconte énormément de choses et
de façons tout l'intérêt de votre livre
et de façon très caricaturale bien
évidemment avec des tirans tels que les
autresut ouais est ce qu'on peut
souligner aussi c'est c'est pas parce
qu'ils ont connu la faim qu'ils vont
avoir de l'empathie pour leur peuple qui
vont laisser crever de faim exactement
c'est chacun sa peau exactement d'autant
plus que on pense notamment à la Grande
Famine souousmao pense aussi euh Lolo de
Mor en Ukraine cette fin organisée cette
famine organisée par le pouvoir
stalinien euh ce sont quand même des des
animaux des animaux politiques à sang
frroid euh eux ça ne les dérange
absolument pas de festoyer pendant que
le le le peuple est en train de mourir
de de faim et même Staline se faisait
raconter des exécutions pendant le repas
où il mourrait de rire ah non au
contraire ça lui mettait de bonne humeur
ù Saddam Hussein pendant la guerre Iran
Irak il aimit bien
regarder certains roches comme on dit
certaines archives de de soldats
iraniens exécutés donc vous voyez un
petit peu c'est quand même une ambiance
un peu particulière on n pas tous la
même notion de ce moment de convivialité
que le moment de table et alors vous
parlez aussi c'est page 34 d'un lien
causal entre la vie intestinale
tourmentée de dictateurs et leur
agissement criminel parce que ce que ce
qu'on sait maintenant ce qu'on ne savait
pas forcément à l'époque de de Mao c'est
que l'intestin c'est le deuxème cerveau
et euh ils sont très très préoccupés par
l'état de leur intestin euh ça fait
penser même à l XIV don dont on
examinait les les selles excusez-moi si
vous êtes à table mais euh h bah il faut
savoir ques sont très très concernés
hein oui alors il faut savoir que bon
euh là effectivement on va pas rentrer
dans tout le détail de la vie
intestinale des uns et des autres mais
il faut savoir que euh Maut setung était
quelqu'un de constipé c'était une
constipation opignâre il n'allait pas la
selle parfois pendant plus d'une semaine
et donc c'était un petit peu compliqué
semaine d'ailleurs pour la petite
histoire l'examen des selles vous avez
bien raison ça me revient en mémoire
alors la première visite que Mao fait en
Union soviétique Staline est au pouvoir
céta en 1950 et bien il est placé dans
une datcha où on a traficoté la
tuyauterie et les canalisations pour
récupérer les selles de Mao et pour les
examiner pour savoir exactement ce qu'il
a dans le ventre au sens premier du
terme au sens propre ouais c'est fou ça
on a quand même on a quand même à faire
ça va
loin ouais tout à fait et alors du coup
euh qu'est-ce que je voulais demander
donc voilà et oui c'est ça en fait on
c'est pas tant ce qu'ils mangent que
comment ils digèrent finalement comment
ils évacuent et et ça peut aussi jouer
sur le leur humeur et leur bah tout à
fait leur prise de de décision vous avez
raison parce que je pense que le moment
de table al ça c'est vrai pour tous les
hommes de pouvoir hein tous les
cuisiniers des grandes semondes me l'ont
dit c'est un moment de détente un petit
peu de voyez c'est un milieu oui c'est
quand même un milieu et des fonctions
qu'ils exercent qui sont extrêmement
stressantes et c'est le moment où en
dehors des repas officiel c'est moment
où il peuvent se lâcher un petit peu et
puis beaucoup qui sont sous pression
beaucoup de ces dictateurs avaient ce
qu'on a aimé la cuisine de la mère la
cuisine de de de leur mère voilà cuisine
maternelle c'est ce que les Anglais
appent voilà comfort food notamment
Saddam Hussein c'est ce qu'on on appelle
la la la nourriture de confort et
effectivement ement c'est ce moment un
peu jovial convivial avec bon une
convivialité assez particulière chez
certains je pense encore à à Joseph
Staline puisque il avait une
convivialité un petit peu sadique dans
le sens où c'était une vodka véritase
dans la mesure où il faisait boire de la
vodka à ses invités en espérant que
peut-être lâcher il allaient se lâcher
tandis que lui il ne buvait que son
fameux vin geéorgien et et donc voilà et
c'est raconté dans les mémoires de dans
les mémoires de Molotov que c'était un
moment terrible pour eux et qu'ils
étaient vraiment sur leur garde et il
faisaient attention malgré les
encouragement de Staline voilà a peur au
ventre et il faisait en sorte de ne pas
trop boire
pour ne pas baisser la garde tout comme
Mao faisait avaler du piment rouge
extrêmement fort à ses invités parce que
ça ça correspondait à à
son sa son idéologie communiste
révolutionnaire et pour lui et c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est que bon
connaissaz la fameuse phrase dis-moi ce
que tu
mange et voilà on pourrait en utiliser
ple d'ut mais lui il don qu'on a dans le
ventre et il donne Mao une lecture
politique déjà il est très proche de sa
cuisine natale il est très comment
Chauvin c'est la province du la la la la
province du unan et donc c'est très
c'est très pimenté et pour lui un vrai
révolutionnaire doit manger pimenté
rouge mange du rouge il mange du piment
rouge et en revanche si on aime les
saveurs un peu mielleuses un petit peu
sucré ça veut dire qu'on est en train de
safadir et qu'on perd un peu du feu
révolutionnaire voilà lecture que le
Grand Timonier faisait de la table oh
mon dieu quel esprit bon alors moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on revienne un peu à
notre
beauassa voilà qui donc a a habité alors
attendez il est il était empereur de la
Centrafrique entre 1976 et 1979 fa
m'arrêter si je dis des bêtises ça peut
m'arriver et en fin anné années 70 il
achète ce fameux château d'Ardre
courourt dans les Ines à de pas d'ici et
il y vit assigné à résidence de 83 à 86
il
est chassé du pouvoir il a été chassé du
pouvoir voilà et il se réfugie là avec
une quinzaine de ses enfants sur les 54
est-ce qu'il a des épouses avec lui sur
les combien il en avait déjà il en avait
beaucoup 17 ou je plus j'en ai perdu le
compte mais vous êtes pas loin je pense
que c'est 17 ça voilà euh
ou 56 enfants déclarer ben voilà après
on sait pas et puis juste pour terminer
bon il meurt en 96 son château est vendu
en 2011 et permet de rembourser une
partie de ses dettes à l'état puisque
étant l'enfant de la France qui lui doit
tout je sais pas quoi enfin il avait pas
à payer ses impôts ceci étant dit pardon
il avait la double nationalité aussi
tout à fait voilà il aimé beaucoup papa
de Gaulle ou exactement voilà et
maintenant je vouis et cousin Valérie et
le cousin valérieà un lien très très
particulier d'ailleurs on retrouve aussi
vous avez raison de mentionner sa double
nationalité ce qu'on oublie un peu il
était effectivement centraafricain et
français il avait servi dans l'armée
française dans la colo il en était très
fier donc il respectait immément il
avait une une admiration sans borne pour
le général de Gaulle quiaelait
effectivement papa le général de Gaulle
lu avait dit arrêté de m'appeler papa
vous imaginez bien et donc et
effectivement dans sa pour le sujet qui
nous
dans sa cuisine dans la table il
cuisinait lui-même il chassait et du
gibier en Sologne mais aussi je crois
dans dans les ivelines
a et donc et il chassait comme il savait
découper luimême sa fille une de ses
filles marieance
bocassa qui a écrit une bio et qui vit
toujours dans les iblines raconte
effectivement à quel point elle était
dégoûtée lorsque elle le voyait dépesser
les bêtes et lui faire manger il
mangeait les les les
coucounnettes sangliers oui et donc
voilà le bokasa oui je voulais juste
dire à ce point est très important cette
double nationalité on la retrouve dans
l'assiette parce que effectivement il
mangeait africain même lorsqu'il était
effectivement exilé dans les iines il
faisait encore livrer euh des choses de
là-bas des produits de là-bas du riz
centrafricain parce qu'il y en avait et
sont riz à lui et donc il aimait encore
avoir une cuisine africaine
centrafricaine mais lorsqu'il recevait
lorsqu'il faisait des des grands grands
dîners il c'était c'était du français
cétait de cuisines la cuisine intime et
la cuisine publique si je puis dire il
faut dire aussi qu'il a été orphelin à
10 ans à 6 ans pardon et excusez-moi et
bah il aimait bien cuisiner justement ça
lui rappelait son enfance triste mais
quand même des des racines dont dont il
restait proche alors du coup euh bah
comme les autres il néprouve aucune
empathie pour son pays alors je parle
pas de quand il était dans les ivelines
mais avant à sa table avant il éprouve
aucune empathie pour son peuple lui il
est il est il organise des banquets
absolument démesuré et grotesques
notamment alors là on peut on est obligé
d'en parler et tout le monde a ça enfin
ceux qui ont un peu plus de 50 ans
maintenant se souviennent du sacre du
sacre de bokasa 1er qui était quand même
une sorte de farce extraordinaire et
avec donc à bangi la capitale de la
République centrafricaine un banquet
majestueux on a fait venir des des des
des meilleures bouteilles de champagne
on a fait venir des pièces montées enfin
bref c'est le dîner du grand siècle qui
est pour une sorte de comment dirais-je
de d'empereur bouffon quelque part et
donc tout est grotesque dans cette
histoire c'est pas adapté à la
température absolument pas la pièce
montée sécoule il y aura même un des
chevaux qui mourra du fait de la chaleur
et et et et il manque on' on m'a raconé
des anecdotes elles sont tellement
comment dirais-je stupéfiantes que j'ai
presque eu de mal à à croire mais
apparemment voilà c'est j'allais venir
j'allais venir des crevettes comme il y
avait eu beaucoup plus de monde ah
c'était la bonne ambiance et donc il y
avait plein de de picassiettes qui était
arrivé et donc il manquait de crevette
et pour faire un ils avaient commencé à
à à mettre
des de gomme pour meubler l'assiette
comme ça pour faire en sorte que les
caméras ne puissent pas montrer que ça
manquit de nourriture au repas du sacre
du de l'empereur 1er de l'empereur
bookasa 1er qui se prenait pour une
sorte de Napoléon des des tropiques un
peu ridicule d'ailleurs il était avec
l'impératrice Catherine qui était très
très gêné parce que c'est un moment
enfin un peu grotesque elle avait
peut-être un peu plus de recul par
rapport à à lui par rapport à cette
farce et elle venait le rendre elle
venait lui rendre visite dans son
château d'ardriour ou là alors que
c'était quand même une c'est une fin un
peu pitoyable hein disons-le la la fin
de de de Jean Bedel bookassa mais
lorsqu'elle était là alors là c'est sa
fille he qui le raconte qui me l'a
raconté pour le besoin de de mon livre à
la table des Tiran à ce moment-là
effectivement il se mettait en costume
631 VO mais ça a été une vie un peu
compliqué pour pour pour les enfants
dans les ilines parce que eux il était
ruiné il était ruiné il était crié
criblé de de de dett ce qu' n'empêchait
pas il avait quand même un peu d'argent
de côté de donner de lâcher un billet de
Fran à l'époque au boucher du coin pour
une sorte de sorte d'escabo d'escalope
pardonesc je pas pourquoi je parle
d'escabo un drô si c'est c'est une sorte
d'escabo d'avoir une belle table c'est
pour se hausser voilà donc voilà et et
donc mariefance bocassa raconte que son
enfance ici dans les n'a pas toujours
été très facile d'autant plus qu'il y
avait cette légende à mon avis c'est
vraiment une légende de cannibalisme et
effectivement je elle était dans d'aller
à l'école j'im voilà on disait ton père
mange des petits enfants est un ogugre
et c'était pas facile et puis eu il
crevaent de faim ils allaient piquer à
la il allent piquer à la superpérette du
coin je crois que c'est hardricour je
sais pas c'est du côté des Mureaux enfin
Mel quelonque et donc voilà c'était
compliqué c'était pathétique pauvre
gosse et pourquoi il lu faisait dîner à
23h
c'est parce que il avait une
conception un peu originale et
folklorique des des oreilles après voilà
après pour les enfants il devait aller à
l'école le lendemain c'était pas évident
mais oui il était un père excusez-moi à
la table des tyrans il était un père
tyrannique mais en même temps moi le
témoignage que j'en ai on a qu'ilimait
bien quand même mais voilà il y avait
quand même malgré tout c'était un tyran
je sais pas si un oxyor mais un tyran
sympathique ouais peut-être attachant
attachiant voilà atttion on va le dire
comme CEL et dites-moi pour terminer
alors cette fameuse rumeur de
cannibalisme parce que il y a un
témoignage dans votre livre quelqu'un
qui a trouvé des corps dans dans le dans
le congélateur c'est pas dans mon livre
je rapporte je rapporte ce qui était dit
dans la presse de l'époque effectivement
des témoignages et effectivement il y a
un cuisinier qui a accusé donc il est
pas le seul hein de de
canimalisme oui il dit amindada il y a
eu aussi ces mais lui-même il dit
amindada a considéré hein le le le Tiran
d'Ouganda a lui-même dit qu'il était
cannibal après on sait pas la part de
provocation qui était aussi pour faire
peur aux occidentaux pour provoquer un
petit peu mais pour revenir à à Jean
Bedel bookasa je pense qu'il y a une
légende qui s'est construite là-dessus
qui était qui visaer à le discréditer et
ce que j'essae et c'est pas du tout mon
intention de réhabiliter euh l'image
ternie de de Jean bedal bookassa mais je
veux quand même dire que il y a un fond
un peu raciste là-dessus c'était un
dictateur c'était un Tiran il est arrivé
à la faveur d'un coup d'État mais
néanmoins il y a pas besoin d'en
rajouter et là on arrive à quelque chose
où où on peut discréditer quelqu'un
parce qu'il mange et là en particulier
là on est quand même dans le pire du
pire on l'accuse de cannibalisme et
finalement il a été jugé deux fois
condamné deux fois en République
centrafricaine et jamais en fait le le
chef de de cannibalisme le chef
d'accusation n'a jamais été retenu donc
il a été au moins même s'il a été
condamné par ailleurs condamné à mort la
peine a été par la suite commuée mais il
n'a pas été condamné pour cannibalis
néanmoins tous les les les journaux qui
ont publié ce qui me semble être une
légende un peu avec un fond raciste
n'ont jamais dit qu'il s'était trompé et
et ça j'ai voulu insister là-dessus
c'est que il y a pas besoin de rajouter
on peut penser tout le mal qu'on veut de
jamb del bocassa mais pourquoi parce que
c'est un tyran africain il faudrait lui
coller l'image de Cannibal je tr et et
et rien ne montre que effectivement ça
s'est prouvé je pense que ça a été à la
fois par le pouvoir français pouvoir
giscardien une façon de le discréditer
par son successeur de discrédité
jeanbudel bocassa parce qu'il restait
relativement populaire enfin tout est
relatif et donc c'était une façon encore
une fois d'utiliser l'arme voyez je vous
disais tout à l'heure que c'est de la
gastrocommunication et bien là c'était
une façon de le diffamer et ça ça n'a
jamais été prouvé l'histoire des des
cadavres trouvé dans sa jambe froide ou
le
le témoignage très folklorique de son
cuisinier qui raconte qu'il voyait des
mains sortir des fours enfin c'était
c'était quand même un peu gros comme
ficelle après on disait aussi que
c'était par politesse au cas où il
aurait eu des des
invités ayant envie de viande humaine
qu'il en ait sous la main pour leur
cuisiné très poiment et ça on mais ça
c'est des des articles qui ont été ça
c'est un témoignage qui a été publié par
Libération journal sérieux normalement
mais qui après par la suite la personne
qui a donné cette interview qui a
raconté queeectivement par politesse on
met on hum comme ça il a dit que c'était
il avait voulu c'était c'était une façon
de faire une farce une façon de piéger
libération et ça a plutôt bien marché
parce que ça et on en parle encore on en
parle encore donc voilà moi c'était
quand même dans ce livre j'ai essayé de
parce que même si je le fais de façon un
peu humoristique parce un peu IR très
très vite très facilement c'est très
très intéressant je veux quand même
qu'il y ait une base du vrai du sérieux
moi je suis journaliste à la base
documentariste c'est un thème que j'aime
beaucoup donc j'ai essayé de faire en
sorte qu' d'enquiéé et de cont soit bien
bien sourcé et cetera et de toute façon
comme vous dites vous-même il y a pas
besoin d'en rajouter je chaque
personnage chaque tyran hein dans cette
table des tyran est suffisamment riche
entre guillemets en en manie et en truc
effroyable que pas besoin de rajouter
des trucs quoi voilà bon ben écoutez
qu'est-ce que je voulais dire d'autre
maintenant je pense que c'est bon on a
fait le tour juste un point que voudrais
ajouter parce que c'est quelque chose
qui m'est souvent posé enfin par les
lecteurs des question
hensib végéis d'adolitler et qui est de
notoriété publi et làdessus là aussi
j'ai essayé d'enquêter le plus
sérieusement possible et même si ça peut
heurter certaines sensibilités parce
qu'on n'associe pas forcément le
végétarisme avec l'hitlerisme si vous
voyez ce que je veux dire et bien
néanmoins il y a un côté qui me semble
très certain c'est qu'il était bien
végétarien qu' mais oui parce que sa
mère est mort d'un cancer à 47 ans et
qu'il avait qu'une trouille c'est de de
mourir aussi du ventre d'un d'un mot
comme ça pensais que c'était plus sain
de manger deit fait le lien il avait
fait le lien effectivement entre les les
CR comprendre il a fait le lien entre le
cancer du colon notamment et la viande
rouge ce qui a été un peu mise en avant
bon voilà ça a été mise en avant à
l'époque et puis maintenant c'est quand
même de notoriéé publique alors bon mais
après ça dénote aussi un esprit
hygiéniste chez Adolf Hitler qui se
retrouve aussi dans dans l'assiette et
qui est qui fait vraiment souvent froid
dans le dos tout à fait même si malgré
ça il nourrissait les petites souris en
sachant voilà enfin bref tout ça on va
arrêter parce que sinon on va raconter
tout le livre que franchement je vous
encourage à l c'est vraiment passionnant
on apprend plein de chos et l'importance
donc de de cette nourriture et de cette
gastro politique qui qui mène le monde
quoi de toute façon entre autres mais
pas mal quand même voilà rou un grand
merci d'être venu jusqu'à nous et puis
bah à bientôt pour d'autres livres ou
documentaires ou sur les les ondes
d'Arté avec grand plaisir mer à très
vite merci merci de nous avoir suivi à
[Musique]
bientôt